crisis talks soaring gas prices and
another energy company asking for
bailout just how many of these
businesses will be left standing by the
end of the year plus the pm in new york
for a key summit somewhat overshadowed
by a row over submarine contracts from
us today's government minister james
cleverley about all of that in just a
moment also the mayor of london sadiq
khan is on the program for us and this
morning we'll talk to the former prime
minister gordon brown on the call to
save a hundred million kovid jabs being
thrown away for being out of date by the
end of the year that is at half past
seven and
we are running out of time
and there's one industry that's
contributing more to our destruction
than any other
counting the cost of our food at 9 45
joined by the documentary maker who says
we're eating our way to extinction it's
monday the 20th of september trying to
keep the lights on one of britain's
biggest energy suppliers sixth bailout
as surging gas prices forced the
government to hold crisis talks with the
industry
keeping climate promises boris johnson
arrives in new york for a u.n summit and
urges rich nations to meet their 100
billion pledge to the developing world
we've made a big big pledge we've
already greatly reduced our our co2 but
we need other countries to step up to
the plate the big emitters around the
world
attacking the new job head on the
foreign secretary liz trusts to call on
iran for the immediate release of nazim
zagari ratcliffe will speak to her
husband this hour
motors detectives call to a house in
derbyshire after four people are found
dead developing story we'll bring you
the very latest in just a moment
lava alert people evacuated as a volcano
erupts on the spot at the spanish island
of la palma
and i'll bring you all of the action
from the emmy awards including michaela
cole's big win on what was a big night
for british talent
i dedicate this story to every single
survivor of sexual assaults thank you
[Music]
morning everybody crisis talks will be
held today on how to help save the uk's
energy industry after another company
asked for a bailout last night to help
it weather the storm of soaring
wholesale gas prices there are fears
over how many energy companies can make
it to the end of the year uk energy
company bulb is seeking a bailout to
stay afloat it comes as wholesale gas
has shot up by
250 percent since january and four small
energy companies have already folded
meanwhile a shortage of carbon dioxide
is also affecting food supplies with the
owners of the uk's biggest poultry
company warning it could affect the
number of turkeys available for
christmas
joined now by the minister for the
middle east and africa james cleverley
representing the government this morning
hello to mr cleverley thank you for
joining us on the programme um what is
the plan to save the gas industry
well quasi-curtain the
energy uh minister the business minister
has had a series of meetings with the
industry to ensure
that the uh consumers in here in the uk
are protected and they're protected both
from the increase potentially in gas
prices through the energy price cap that
we have in place but also to ensure that
we have continuity of supply and the
message that
he's put out and he put out a series of
tweets that people could look at if they
wish to
is that because of the mix of where we
get our energy from we are in a better
place than many other countries that are
also feeding the pinch from this
increase in wholesale gas supply
and that we will absolutely do
everything we can to
protect consumers to make sure we have a
vibrant
uh energy supply market
55 businesses i believe in the sector
according to this morning's uh front
page of the financial times there could
only be six to ten left by the end of
the year that according to the industry
this is pretty grim stuff
well as i say uh the the business
secretary has uh already
had a series of meetings uh he will be
having others i am certain
and what we are doing is working to
ensure that we do two things and that is
to protect consumers from what has been
a a global increase in gas prices
but also
to ensure the uh security of energy
supply and energy provision
to those consumers and
we're in a pretty good place here in the
uk because of course we have our own
domestic gas supply but we also receive
gas from really very reliable partners
like norway for example so we're in a
better place than many other countries
around the world
will the government bear like small
suppliers who are in danger of going
bust
well as i say the the business secretary
has had and will continue to have
meetings with the sector
the priority is to make sure that we
protect provision for consumers and to
ensure that they aren't hit by
uh
unforeseeable or unpredictable a
significant increase in gas prices
and and those discussions will be
ongoing exactly how we do that will be
up for uh discussion of course but those
are our priorities
so that's not on no then is it i mean if
if we see all these businesses starting
to potentially go bust in order to try
to protect people's gas supplies the
government's going to have to step in
and help them aren't there
well as i say i'm not going to speculate
as to exactly how we do this but i can
assure you that the conversations that
the business sector has already had
have been very
productive and we will ensure we will
ensure the protection of consumers as i
say from the price inflations that we're
seeing all over the world but also we're
very very conscious of the importance of
protecting that energy supply as well
so again the article that i'm referring
to i'm sure you've seen it on the front
of the ft this morning talks about a
northern style
bad bank where um if there are lots of
people whose gas suppliers are going
under they all need to be put under one
umbrella protected by the state in order
to make sure that all of the other
businesses don't go under as well i'm
guessing that just gov good governance
means that you have to be looking at
something like that
well as i say we're considering the
options and i'm not
i'm not going to speculate as to exactly
how we addressed this but we've moved
quickly the business secretary of state
has already had a series of meetings uh
about this both last week uh and over
the weekend and we've got a very clear
idea of what our priorities need to be
in terms of protecting consumers and
protecting
the security of our energy supply so
you're not ruling it out then
okay you keep asking me and i keep
giving you the same answer we are
considering a range of options the
business sector has met with the
the energy supply companies
and our priorities are to protect
consumers and also to protect the
security of our energy supply and we
will look we'll look at a range of
options no doubt but i'm not going to
rule anything in or commit to anything
here on uh on your show this morning i'm
afraid okay let me drive from a
different angle i'm sure my viewers very
anxious this morning about what's going
to happen as far as their gas is
concerned if they or energy bills are
concerned when they hear that of 55
companies only six out of six to ten
could be left standing by the end of the
year
how
potentially might the public be expected
to pay for that there is a an energy
price cap of 139 pounds for next month
um could that go higher
well the energy price cap is there not
to
uh
completely prevent
energy prices ever going up but it's
about making sure that there are no
sudden unexpected unpredictable uh big
hikes in prices so the energy price cap
uh has always been designed uh designed
to move gently upwards but the big thing
is to prevent
as i say big unpredictable spikes in
consumer prices the other thing of
course that the government has put in is
a whole series of
measures to protect the poorest families
uh in the country through things like um
winter fuel support and also to make it
easier for people to switch providers to
get the best deals so as i say our
priority remains to protect consumers
and also to protect the security of our
energy supply so just to clarify that
139 pound lift
cap for next month that is going to stay
at that until six months time when you
look at it again
yeah as i say it's about providing
predictability
for consumers and that the energy price
cap policy
is in place it has protected uh hundreds
of thousands of consumers already and
will continue to do so okay how worried
are we about food supplies um and the
like and concerns about carbon dioxide
it's a little bit complicated but just
for the benefit of our viewers this
morning
we haven't got enough carbon dioxide it
could mean that
animal husbandry is a challenge over the
next couple of weeks and also some
operations within the nhs and i found it
surprising that you need carbon dioxide
for some um nhs hospital operations
apparently but but you do um
what is being put in place by the
government to make sure that that supply
is sorted out
well the
the the points that you raise uh once
again we find ourselves in a situation
that many countries in the world are
experiencing um the
the logistics industry which underpins a
lot of the
movement of uh products like co2 we we
know the uh the situation there and what
we're looking to do is twofold firstly
is to make sure that in the in the
medium term and beyond that the uk is
increasingly self-sufficient
in terms of things like food production
but also in terms of uh people in the
logistics change that chain hgb drivers
that kind of stuff
and in the shorter term obviously we are
looking across government at what we
need to do to address what might be some
uh short-term shortages in these things
again these are things that we're
discussing we're discussing with the
industry we discuss them across
government and we will ensure that we
are able to put food on the tables
obviously that is a real priority uh and
as i say we're looking across government
and how we address this okay so alex
sharma has been talking about it as you
say you've quoted him several times
during the course of the interview he's
pretty relaxed about things at the
moment prime minister on his way to new
york less relaxed saying that there will
be some supply shortages where are you
sitting on that scale well we we already
know that
right across the world we have seen
for example htv drivers and it's not
unique to the uk a shortage of hgv
drivers as i say we are taking measures
to uh address that and you say about the
uh the prime minister uh traveling to
new york and a big part of the
uh the work he is going to do there is
actually to get the world focused on
some of the issues that we have to
address collectively to make sure that
we have things like food security in the
future and addressing uh climate change
is a really important part of that and
that's very much part of the
conversations that he'll be having over
in new york at the united nations
general assembly he's taken this trust
with him um she says that one of her
main issues is to try and get nazinin
zagari ratcliffe and the other brits out
of iran um
where will she succeed where three
previous foreign secretaries have failed
well we are absolutely determined to get
back all the british dual nationals
currently held in our
arbitrary detention
by uh iran um she's having meetings with
her iranian uh opposite number and that
will uh and that will be uh the release
of our um dual nationals will very much
be at the top of the agenda it always is
when we have um negotiations with the
iranians
and we will continue pushing and we will
not rest until we get them all home
their
incarceration is is arbitrary it's
completely unjustified and we've made it
clear that we will not stop
uh working to get those um british
nationals home
how confident are you that your new boss
will succeed there where others have
failed
well it is never easy negotiating um
with the iranian uh leadership um but i
have no doubt that she will uh you know
she's an incredibly focused and
energetic minister she's uh well
regarded
for that and i have no doubt that she
will apply uh that energy to these
negotiations and we will continue
pushing and pushing and pushing until we
get our british dual nationals home are
you confident that she'll be able to
succeed this time
well
i mean
i can speculate but what's the point in
speculating the point is
that we raise this whenever we have
meetings with the iranian leadership
we will
we will keep pushing on this we will
explore what avenues um
uh you know can be taken to get our
british dual nationals home all of our
british dual nationals
how anxious are you that we've upset the
french to such an extent over this um
submarine deal that they've called off
talks uh defence talks uh scheduled for
later on in the week
well the
i mean this the the agreement that uh we
have come to with the united states of
america and australia about uh submarine
manufacture it's it's not about france
it is about our very strong relationship
with united states america and australia
it's about reinforcing an incredibly
important and strong
defense
relationship and it is also about making
sure that we have high-tech
manufacturing jobs here in the uk that's
what this is about obviously
with any international relationship
there are ups and downs and i am no
doubt that we will ultimately resolve
any frictions that there are
currently with france but this is
actually about making sure that a we are
protected and b that we are um closely
aligned with two of our strongest uh and
most long-standing uh defence and
security partners in the world but the
french are a key defense ally aren't
they and they are so offended that
they've recalled two of their
ambassadors from australia and from the
us and called off key defense talks here
in the uk later on this week there's
going to have to be some
key discussions going on with the french
in order to try to bring them back on
side why don't we just include them in
the conversation to start with
well the as i say this
uh agreement was about our relationship
our defense relationship with the united
states of america
and uh australia and obviously
it wasn't really was it what we did was
they'd done a deal with the aussies and
we said we can offer you a better deal
and our submarines are better so forget
about that deal that you've done and
we'll sell you ours instead don't tell
the french
well
i i i think i think viewers would be
amazed if they didn't think that the uk
was a
a competitive
and
um
internationally engaged country that's
what we that's what we are that's what
we do we made our position absolutely
clear but um this is uh global britain
we're engaging with the world and we are
working with our partners all across the
world including united states of america
including australia
this is an incredibly
we literally pulled the rug from under
them they had a deal 40 odd billion
quids worth uh yeah quidsworth um and we
pulled a rug from one of them we said
don't do that deal with them we've got
better ones than they have
well the uh the contractual relationship
between australia and france is for
australia and france what this is about
is the uk
being engaged with two of our longest
standing and closest defense partners in
the world
it's about making sure that the
the world is kept safe and it's about
making sure that we support the
manufacturing
industry the high-tech manufacturing
manufacturing industry here in the uk
and every part of the uk
uh wales scotland northern ireland and
all parts of the uk including the
midlands and the north of of england so
this is this is about that
and as i say the the relationship
between um or the contractual
relationship
uh between australia and france is
something that they will have to discuss
okay finally before i let you go
you know you can accept why the french
are a little bit miffed with us this
morning though
as i say this this is about
our defense and security and this is
about making sure that the uk government
supports uk
businesses in every part of the uk
that's what this is about
okay
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us on the program hopefully you'll come
and see us next time it's good to see
you mr cleverley always thank you
um our correspondent aisha zaid is at
the oval gas works for us so once one of
the big in fact the biggest gas works in
the world uh she's with us now hello to
you good morning good morning big
problems with gas supplies
yeah absolutely really worrying for
energy firms we know two have already
gone bust and bulb have said that they
are seeking a bailout to stay afloat now
uh now
it's it comes amid these prices rising
they've increased by 250 since the year
began and since august alone the price
increase has been 70
it comes down to a number of factors
first of all a colder winter last year
has been blamed for depleting stocks as
well as an increased demand in gas from
asia while there's been a decrease in
supply from russia
and it's energy firms feeling the brunt
of this but there is a spillover effect
with the food industry feeling knock-on
effect from all of it the food retailers
and food producers have warned that
christmas dinner could be cancelled this
year amid shortages of foods including
chicken and turkey and that's an
indirect effect of these gas price
heights because two fertilizer plants in
the uk have uh have had to seize
production and they produce a by-product
of carbon dioxide which is needed with
various food processes
okay
thanks for the update really appreciate
it thanks a lot
front page of the financial times this
morning suggesting that we could be left
with between six and ten energy
companies by the end of the year
presently we have 55 four have gone
under in the last month alone what on
earth is going on we'll be talking about
that talking about that i should say
throughout the course of the programme
for you here on sky news today and as we
were discussing there also with mr
cleverley the prime minister is in the
big apple for a key un summit despite
that row over submarine contracts he's
got tackling climate change on his mind
as our political editor beth rigby
reports from new york
coming into land in new york the uk
prime minister's first trip overseas
since the start of the pandemic
back to the city of his birth for the
united nations general assembly a global
gathering of politicians facing global
challenges and the pm tasks with trying
to galvanize action on perhaps the
biggest of them all climate change
this is a crucial summit absolutely
crucial uh for
the next couple of months it's only a
couple of months now till uh the cop 26
summit and so we need everybody to focus
on what's called their nationally
determined contributions that's the
amount of carbon dioxide each country is
going to is going to cut the uk is
way out in front or where is doing very
well we've made a big big pledge we've
already greatly reduced our our co2 but
we need other countries to step up to
the plate uh the big emitters around the
world the us one of those emitters and
the pm here to line up hard cash but
nothing is guaranteed boris johnson is
known for his tendency to over promise
but at this critical summit in new york
which one officials described to me as
an important staging post on the way to
cop he's been
uncharacteristically downbeat about the
prospect of securing financial
commitments from other developed nations
to help tackle climate change perhaps
he's learnt the art of expectation
management
more likely he knows just how difficult
truly global agreement will be
relations between boris johnson and joe
biden have been strained in recent weeks
over the chaotic evacuation from kabul
this their first face-to-face meeting
since the withdrawal and a test of the
pm's diplomacy when bush comes to such
of mr johnson is a tough pragmatic
politician who knows how to get from a
to b and in that respect
not many people might admit it in that
respect he's not dissimilar
to
president biden from the nhs and social
care plan to the cabinet reshuffle
the pm has set out his domestic agenda
in the past few weeks
this week here his attention turns to
international ambitions beth rigby sky
news new york
uh of course we'll monitor what the
prime minister has to say uh when he
wakes up in new york in just a few hours
time let me just show you our climate
change indicator board though top line
there you go shows how the uk's power
is produced um
and oh 64 fossil fuels today that's
quite high it's not normally that high
is it and you can see how much warmer
the earth is now than in 1880 that's the
second row for you that's when modern
records
began in 1880 then the figure to how
long scientists believe it will take to
reach the plus 1.5 degrees celsius
figure seen by many as a point of no
return for the planet that's the third
row and finally a huge and frightening
statistic the total amount of co2
emissions in millions of tons
and keep up with all of the stories
affected by climate change on the daily
climate show right here at live on sky
news every weekday at half past six
spectacular pictures reaching us from
the canary islands today on the island
of la palma it's been setting the sky a
light overnight these are live pictures
for you
jets of lava
a lot um have been erupting into the air
along with plume of smoke and ash it
follows a week-long build-up of seismic
activity prompting authorities to
evacuate thousands lava flows destroyed
isolated houses and threatened to reach
the coast no
injuries injuries i should say have been
reported at this stage still to come on
the program for you
a warning that 100 million covered cabs
or should that be jabs could go to waste
at 7 30. i'll be joined by the former
prime minister gordon brown as he calls
on world leaders to avoid vaccine
disaster by throwing the doses away
the foreign secretary will use a meeting
with the iranian foreign minister today
to call the immediate release of nazim
zagari ratcliffe who is speaking to her
husband richard at 7 35
and at 8 20 will speak to the chief exec
of the british meat processors
association on what the shortage of
carbon dioxide means for food supply in
the run-up to christmas
also making news for you this morning
and a man has been arrested after four
people were found dead at a house near
sheffield derbyshire police said they
were called to an address on chandos
crescent in killer marsh yesterday
morning police have urged anyone with
information about the incident to come
forward
folic acid is to be added to flower
across the uk in a drive to reduce
life-threatening spinal conditions in
babies the government has said that
adding vitamin b to wholemeal wheat
flour could help prevent around 200
cases a year
the body's been found matching the
description of the missing blogger gabby
potito in the u.s state of wyoming the
22 year old had been on a road trip with
her boyfriend
but her family reported her missing when
mr laundry returned home without her
earlier this month he also disappeared
days later after being declared a person
of interest in the case
harvey weinstein will be brought before
a court in los angeles today to face 10
sexual assault charges the disgraced
film producer is currently serving a
23-year sentence for sexual assault but
has been extradited from new york to
california to face a new criminal
complaint containing allegations from
five women between 2004 and 2013.
now it's been a huge night for uk talent
at one of tv's glitziest events the
emmys overnight in the us kate winslet
michaela cole and olivia coleman have
all picked up awards for i may destroy
you the crown and sky's mayor of east
town our arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer stayed up
all night to watch the proceedings and
has this report
michaela cole
it was arguably the win of the night not
an easy watch but michaela cole's
hard-hitting drama i may destroy you
thoroughly deserved its writing
recognition in a night dominated by
british talent
i dedicate this story to every single
survivor of sexual assaults thank you
just like the old days the glamour was
back the a-listers packed in together
you had to get facts to come here you
know what i mean
i got vacs
i did not have a reaction like nicki
minaj's cousin's friend okay
among all those men
i don't mind it
while netflix's most watched series to
date the queen's gambit one outstanding
limited series
[Music]
the one thing that no algorithm can
predict and no billion dollar budget can
manufacture
is word of mouth
just six months between us oh
and who is the senior
aisle
it was a night of royal deference with
the crown taking home outstanding drama
series and awards for the actors who
played prince charles margaret thatcher
and the queen
olivia coleman the crown
an emotional ending for olivia coleman
who now leaves the show
i wish my dad was here to see this
so
i lost my daddy during covid and um he
would have loved all of this you and
mcgregor
ewan mcgregor was recognised for his
acting in fashion drama holston as was
kate winslet for sky atlantis gritty
crime drama mayor of east town
i just want to acknowledge my fellow
nominees in this decade that has to be
about women having each other's backs i
support you i salute you
[Applause]
not only a great night for homegrown
talent with broadcasters and streaming
services having clocked record audience
figures during the pandemic this was a
celebration of everything that's kept us
going
[Music]
katie spencer sky news
the government says it's considering a
range of options as the energy companies
face a crisis amid surging wholesale gas
prices speaking to the programme in the
last hour the foreign office minister
james cleverley refused to rule anything
out but set out the government's
priorities to protect consumers and
supply
we are considering a range of options
the business sector has met with the
uh um the energy supply companies and
our priorities are to protect consumers
and also to protect the security of our
energy supply and we will look we'll
look at a range of options no doubt but
i'm not going to rule anything in or
commit to anything
tamara's here um i think he rather
underestimated potentially some would
say the level of threat to the industry
yes absolutely the headlines all
dominated by this huge rising global gas
prices and what it means for consumers
even boris johnson on his way to new
york was asked about it and he said that
it would be temporary as we come out of
covid the prime minister compared it to
everyone switching the kettle on after a
tv program had finished but this is
deadly serious for the energy companies
because they have got this price cap
that the government introduced so our
bills are all going to go up by around
140 pounds next month not going to go
higher than that and for a lot of people
that will be a huge amount but the
energy companies are saying that because
of these enormous prices they're having
to pay for wholesale that simply isn't
enough with predictions that almost all
of the energy companies including some
of the bigger ones could go bust by the
end of the year and we're already seeing
industry sources saying in these talks
with the government which mr cleverley
said would be continuing today they want
not just loans but a full northern rock
style financial crisis style bailout
with perhaps even what they're calling a
bad bank so sort of lender of last
resort set up for all those customers
whose energy companies can no longer
provide for them so some big questions
from government about what sort of
infrastructure they might need to set up
around this even if it's temporary may
take weeks or months to sort out and as
far as uh nazisgary ratcliffe is
concerned we've got a new uh foreign
secretary justin post for a few days
already
in new york with the prime minister
already having uh talks with the
iranians later on today how confident
was mr cleverley that something might
come of it well liz trust has already
spoken to nazanin zagari's zagari
ratcliff's husband richard only three
days into the job she's meeting with the
iranian foreign minister in the margins
of this un summit that will be the first
foreign minister level meeting for three
years how can she succeed where previous
foreign secretaries have failed she says
she'll again call for the immediate
release of british detainees in iran but
there's been no mention so far of this
400 million pound debt which the
iranians are linking to her continued
detention the government always says is
not linked okay for now tamara thank you
tomorrow's take at uh nine o'clock this
morning of course here on the programme
so liz uh trust speaking to richard
radcliffe earlier in the week let's
speak to him now should we nazinam's
husband hello to richard always good to
talk to you you managed to have a chat
with the new foreign secretary how
confident are you that she will be able
to do something that others have failed
um you know thank you you're right i i
was very pleased to be able to speak to
her yesterday she called me um at the
airport on her way to
new york she'll be meeting with the
iranian foreign minister today
and in all honesty i don't think she
knows quite how it's going to go and
certainly from here i don't think we
know either um there's been you know
lots of foreign secretaries have met
with the iranians lots of negotiations
have been happening particularly past
year um very intensively um and i spoke
to the former foreign secretary about a
month ago where he said listen we got
really close but we didn't get it over
the line so i think there's been a
change of leadership in iran as well um
we need to see where things are and
whether things are kind of where they
were in which case it could be quite
hopeful or whether they've slipped back
a long way um i see it here obviously
you know we've had a lot of up and downs
so not very confident um
preparing as to whether we need to to go
tough or not and obviously over the
weekend we sent in a request to the
foreign office to sanction some iranians
involved in hostage taking so clearly we
we were feeling we are feeling that this
may have a while to run still
yeah i i was about to ask you richard
how do you stop yourself from feeling
we've been here before
well that's right we we have um there's
been lots of ups and downs and and
i mean this is our fifth foreign
secretary so lots of new starts um i i
think i felt
um i mean often when you meet the
minister for the first time they're
quite cautious and guarded and finished
telling us she was she was quite open
let me speak and explain this is what i
think needs to happen and it was
laid out there a mixture of carrot and
stick she needs to address the
underlying issues but she also
needs to make sure that iran doesn't
carry on practicing hostage diplomacy um
but yeah we've had a lot of ups and
downs it's it's coming up to 2000 days
um she's what five and a half years uh
this week um so
part of me is is you know keeping going
in case things drag on
yeah 3000 days i think on thursday if
i'm not mistaken richard how is she
coping
um you actually more reassured following
the phone call i had with the new
foreign secretary um
bereft is perhaps too strong but but
certainly very disoriented last week
when when there was a capital reshuffle
um dominic rabb had over the time built
up a good relationship with her and you
know when she got taken in uh when
convicted back in the spring phoned her
up a couple of times and then just let
her you know cry at him for an extended
period so i think she
she had felt that he was really on the
case and now
with a new person it takes time to build
but um iran nothing's actually happened
recently um she was convicted um she
is due to go back to prison but we're
waiting for an appeal date before that
gets confirmed that appeal hasn't been
scheduled now for a number of months so
you know it's an uncertain time and
there are moments where she can feel
very low but moments where also
she just lives day to day
so dominic ram had spoken to her and and
listened to her and and just let her
vent her emotion um sadly still
couldn't bring her home how's the baby
coping
uh yeah no gabriel's getting bigger um i
mean you know like cool things there are
days where she wants a mummy and that's
partly just you know a special situation
partly just wanting a second opinion
from daddy when he was suggesting
bedtime um
she's okay
with you know
i mean yeah it was tough around
um
[Music]
countdown for that um when we do the
2000 days and
she comes to that then it'll be a bit
tough but generally we try not to expose
her too much to what's going on and how
are you doing
actually more more upbeat than i was a
couple of days back um
you know i i think you know as
he said in the show that you know
this trust makes us three days into the
job that that's the earliest we've ever
been spoken to as a foreign foreign
secretary it felt a positive sign that
she did it and the fact that she was
open felt a positive sign there i don't
know what i don't know i don't know
what's going to happen i suspect the
government doesn't at this stage um
we'll be ready to push on if we need to
but but hopefully we won't need to so
yeah more positive than i was a couple
days back i was going to say and how are
you really doing
uh yeah well it's obviously been a long
haul um
and hopefully it will end soon and i
rely on an awful lot of people to keep
me supported both people at work and
family and so on
very grateful to all the support we've
received
we're always here to have a chat if you
want to give us a call at any time
richard thank you very much indeed for
talking to us this morning welcome on
the show whenever
let's talk about prince andrew he's been
accused of actively evading formal
efforts to serve him with a lawsuit on
behalf of virginia du frey who has
accused him of battery and intentional
infliction of emotional distress over
alleged misconduct from about two
decades ago the prince denies all of the
allegations against him joined now by
the solicitor and legal commentator
joshua rosenberg hello to joshua thanks
for joining us on the programme this
morning where are we with this case
well we're waiting to see what happens
in new york
there's been this very unseemly row over
whether prince andrew has been properly
served with the court papers in other
words whether they've been formally
delivered to him or not
and it's got very complicated but i
think it boils down to the very simple
fact that the judge will decide that
because prince andrew was represented by
a lawyer at the hearing last week it's
simple enough to send those papers to
his lawyer and that will be sufficient
to ensure that he is aware of the case
of course he's aware of the case we're
all aware of the case the court papers
are very widely circulated i mean it's
you know the stump that we were looking
at there where they sort of the they
took a photograph of putting the
documents in the post um that of course
was uh for the benefit of the media but
um her team does say they've gone an
awful long way to try to serve the
prince what actually has to happen in
order for the case to proceed further
there's the easy way and the aggressive
way the easy way is
for
the defendant in this case prince andrew
to tell his lawyers to accept service of
the claim that means it's just sent to
the lawyers by post by email
it's all private no stunts and the case
can then proceed there's the difficult
way which is to say i didn't receive it
i wasn't at home you need to prove that
it was handed to me or my representative
and so on and that's fine as part of
litigation that's the sort of thing that
litigation lawyers do they want to
appear tough to the other side they
don't want to make it easy at the start
because they want the upper hand in any
future settlement negotiations now that
works in many cases but it doesn't look
good in this case where you have a
member of the royal family who seems to
be avoiding uh this very formal uh and
and trivial matter really of the
documents that he's read and knows all
about being formally delivered to him
so he's gone to balmoral at least for
now and papers being delivered um by a
pi or whoever um at the place in windsor
and they're saying go away he's not here
go away he's not here don't know who he
is sorry um
then we see his lawyer in lay being told
by the judge who's getting more and more
frustrated you accept the papers on his
behalf because i've had enough of this
um
if they don't at some stage they have to
accept that he has been served don't
they so then what happens next
the court can certainly decide that he
has been served because the papers will
have been sent to this entertainment
lawyer rattler in in uh
he's based in los angeles as you say and
then the case goes on um now there are
all sorts of questions coming up as to
the legal tactics that may be involved
um the prince is saying that uh uh
virginia giffare did some sort of deal
in which she agreed that she wouldn't
claim against anybody else because of a
previous settlement now that's a private
deal we don't know what it says we don't
know what its relevance will be and the
case proceeds we haven't really got off
the starting block at the moment because
of this
rather unseemly dispute over whether the
documents have been served to him but i
think at some point in the future uh the
prince's lawyers will decide that the
best thing to do
is to enter into negotiations now you
don't want to show any sign of weakness
and of course you've got to tough it out
until the last possible moment
but i can't see the duke of york wanting
to go to new york and give oral evidence
before a jury i can see all sorts of
unexpected and adverse consequences of
that and so i presume that at some point
then lawyers will negotiate a deal
yeah i think this is going to run and
run for a while though don't you joshua
that depends on the lawyers and that
depends on the approach that they take
and of course it depends on the uh the
instructions that they are given by
their client you can never tell with a
case like this whether it's the lawyers
encouraging the client to do something
or the client encouraging the lawyers to
do something but i think that a lot of
people and we saw a report yesterday of
this in buckingham palace are concerned
at the way this is playing out in the
media and a lot of people want a rather
different approach by his lawyers and if
he can't
get his lawyers to agree to a different
approach maybe he needs different
lawyers
okay a very interesting point it's
always great to see you thank you very
much indeed joshua thank you
of course we will monitor every twist
and turn on that story for you and also
want to bring you up to date with what
is happening out with the pandemic
covert 19 latest
data for the uk and it's looking
something like this a further 29 600 new
cases of coronavirus reported in the
latest 24-hour period a further 56
people have died sadly after contracting
covet takes the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test to just over 135
000. more than twenty five thousand
first doses of the covet vaccine were
given yesterday seventy one thousand
people received their second dose
almost forty four and a half million
people are now fully vaccinated
the former prime minister gordon brown
is warning a hundred million doses of
the covert vaccine will expire by
december and could be thrown away he's
urging world leaders to create a plan to
prevent the jams being wasted as they
prepare to meet for a global vaccine
summit later this week mr brown is with
us now hello to you mr brown thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning what are you hoping for from
this emergency summit good morning
well we have a plan and we get the
vaccines out to those people who need
them so only two percent of africa
vaccinated only two percent of
low-income countries it's in our
interest in britain that they are
vaccinated because the disease will
spread in africa it will mutate and
there'll be new variants it will come
back to haunt even the fully vaccinated
in britain unless we take action so
we've been stopped by vaccines we've got
a mountain of vaccines in america and in
europe
they're not going to be used even when
we do the boosters and the 12 to 15 year
olds there are still millions of
vaccines left over and we've got to get
them to the rest of the world otherwise
they're going to pass the use by date
and expire and be of no use to anybody
and all of us hate waste
so i don't understand why it's not as
easy as opening up the belly of a
british airways jet putting them on
board and taking them down to joburg
well you've done charity work in africa
and you know that there's a desperate
need to get the vaccines into africa as
quickly as possible
and that's what should be being done and
so in june they had a plan that they
would give does share as they called it
when they had excess vaccines they'd
pass them over but it hasn't really
happened enough and yet there's all
these vaccines lying in warehouses or on
contract for delivery to britain america
and europe and yet we don't need them so
we've got to get them out as quickly as
possible wednesday's summit should agree
a plan and it's in everybody's interests
our interests to protect ourselves as
well as to help people in other
countries do you have a plan do you know
how we should do it
yep my plan is that
this month we could transfer 300 million
vaccines that's from american europe by
next month there could be 500 million
and by december a billion and so we need
to get all the resources at our disposal
to airlift them to get them out to the
countries that need them get the
vaccinations happening and provide some
support as you know okay from your
visits to africa uh we need to give help
to administer the vaccines as well but
that's something we've also put in train
and i've been working with the world
health organization and other
organizations to make that happen as
quickly as possible do we have enough
people because that was going to be my
next point you know we're struggling as
far as the nhs is concerned here we
haven't got any people that we can send
to put these jabs in people's arms so
what do we do we get the vaccines there
they're all there on the runway then
what do we do with them
well there's hundreds of thousands of
health workers
in the low-income countries and across
africa they've not even been vaccinated
yet you know
to vaccinate all the health workers is a
huge task so that's going to happen
quickly because they're risking their
lives to save lives then we get to the
vulnerable elderly and then we get to
the rest of the population so that
africa and low-income countries can also
go back to work they're suffering
because
massive unemployment as well as massive
poverty as a result of this
i fear that unless we take this action
then africa could become the center for
covert and if in future you have new
variants and mutations coming out of
africa then it really will hurt the rest
of the world so it's in africa's
interests it's in our interests yes you
can devise a plan very quickly and
wednesday's summit they shouldn't go
around the table saying uh
congratulating themselves and what
they're doing they should go around the
table and say let's get a plan and let's
get all these surplus vaccines out there
and get them used because as i say
what i hate most of all about this is
waste
because we've got genius of scientists
we've got the manufacturers in
delivering one and a half billion
vaccines a month and then they're lying
in warehouses
and not being used that's not good
enough and we in britain and people in
america and europe have got to get their
vaccines out to people who need them as
you say and has often been quoted as
saying and nobody's safe unless
everybody's safe one wonders why all of
these vaccines are going to waste we
seem to have stalled here in the united
kingdom
in making sure that people are double
vaccinated i was looking at the figures
this morning 65 less than two-thirds of
the british public have been fully
vaccinated we used to lead europe and
now we're something like seventh eighth
portugal spain lots of other european
countries ahead of us what's happened
well in america and in europe as well as
in britain there is resistance among
some people to vaccinate and i want to
appeal to everybody who's not been
vaccinated
to get vaccinated and that helps them it
helps their families it helps protect
our communities so there is some
resistance and we've got to deal with
that but even if we set aside enough
vaccines for all who need them
and haven't asked for them yet and do
the boosters and do 3 million 12 to 15
year olds and get them vaccinated twice
which is 6 million vaccine vaccinations
we still have uh millions of vaccines
left over and by christmas that will be
a hundred million if we don't airlift
them to africa and elsewhere it could be
200 million because of the delays in
getting them to people
and that is an excess above all the
other vaccinations that we still want to
see happen in the united kingdom
what do you think of these anti-vaxxers
with their bull horns who uh wander
around shopping centers on a saturday
intimidating people and saying that it's
a government ploy to try and tag us all
well look i admire those people who are
not in politics and not really in
public life in the political sphere
who've gone out and said as individuals
like gareth southgate get vaccinated
and i think we need role models to
appeal to
young people and to the rest of
community not to listen to these
anti-vexes because already we have
proved that a hundred thousand lives
have been saved in britain as a result
of vaccination
and if you think ahead to the next year
the estimate is that a million deaths
will happen across the world unless we
get vaccinations to people and that's a
huge figure of wasted lives as a result
of having wasted vaccines and so we
really have to act to persuade people to
get the vaccination but also to use the
vaccines we've got
sarah gilbert who was one of the
inventors of the astrazeneca vaccine she
has been appealing to people to get the
vaccination and to get the vaccines out
to the rest of the world so people that
everybody can respect for their genius
and for their scientific achievement and
people in the world of sport and so on
are appealing to people to get
vaccinations i make that appeal today as
well
let me ask you um as a former prime
minister while i've got you've seen this
big argument that's developing between
us and the french at the moment because
um they had done a deal with the
australians to have um submarines
diesel-powered submarines and we've gone
behind their backs the french would say
and and done a deal with the americans
to to provide them with nuclear
submarines would you have done it in
that way um if you'd still been prime
minister
well i think we could have done it
better just as we could have done the
afghanistan exit a lot better and i
think there are lessons to learn and i
hope when boris johnson meets president
biden they'll discuss how the whole of
the west can work more closely together
but i think france also has an issue
here they want to if you like to have
strategic autonomy in europe and so they
will build this up as an argument
against working just with nato they want
a sort of french led european defense uh
capacity so
i i think france has its own motives for
building this up but i think we've got
to learn to work better together there
is a standoff with china at the moment
if the west cannot unite and say what it
wants to see done then i don't think
we're going to be in a very strong
position to influence world events in
america and i think boris johnson should
say this to joe biden tomorrow america
used to act unilaterally because it was
a unipolar age and they had complete
hegemony now we're in a multi-polar age
and they've got to work with other
countries and britain and america's
partnership is really important to that
so i hope on practical decisions that
are made tomorrow when boris johnson
meets president biden we can see the
alliances working far better than they
did in afghanistan
but how concerned are you that you know
our closest defense ally in the form of
the french i've withdrawn their
ambassadors from australia and also from
the u.s and have pulled out of defense
talks with the united kingdom later on
in the week now you know they're french
they might be a little bit sulky about
it but they are our closest defense
allies we do need to work with them
while uh organizations like the
americans are keeping an eye on what's
happening in the far east
yeah well as i've said i think this is
more to do with french domestic politics
i think president macron is asserting uh
the importance that he attaches to
french
involvement in the defense of the west
and the defense of the world and i think
this will blow over pretty pretty
quickly in my view but what we've got to
watch is that there's a split over time
between the french wanting to take
europe one way
and the americans britain and nato
wanting to go another way i think that's
something we must leave it there mr
brown i'm so sorry we're out of time
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning thank you
[Music]